[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES LAU: Hello.
Good afternoon, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
We're so excited
to be here today.
We know you have a
choice of sessions,
so thank you for choosing us,
and being here today with us.
I am James, and I work
on Android Studio.
And here with me
today is Jerome.
He's the tech lead for the
build system in Android Studio.
So we're here today
to talk about one
of our favorite topics, which
is how to speed up your Android
Gradle builds.
Now, slow build speed is a
huge productivity buster.
It's kind of like
driving down the road
and constantly hitting speed
bumps after speed bumps.
We've heard you
loud and clear that
build speed is critical
to your productivity.
That's why we've been focused
for the past several quarters
on improving our build
speed performance.
Now, to give you
some context on why
we're so excited to talk
about this subject today--
over the past year, we've been
hosting a series of developer
build clinics.
In these build clinics, we meet
with developers one on one,
and they would come
to us and tell us
about their build
performance issues.
Now, we would play
doctor in these clinics,
which is kind of fun.
But the most surprising
part of this-- and this
was surprising to us, is
that more often than not,
we would be able to speed up
their development built by 3x,
4x, sometimes even up to 10x by
applying a simple set of tips.
And that set of tips is what
we will share with you today.
Now, our talk today will be
structured into three parts.
First, I'm going to
talk about the tips
for improving your
projects' development belts.
Second, Jerome is
going to talk to you
about how you can make the most
out of the new Android Gradle
plugin 3.0 that we just
released yesterday.
And finally, he will wrap up
by talking about some tools
and best practices on how
to debug and profile your
build performance issues.
So now, let's talk
about the tips
for speeding up your builds.
So what I'm going to
show you is that I'm
going to present these
tips to you one at a time.
And what I'm also going
to do is that I'm also
going to use the Santa
Tracker project as an example
to show you the impact
of each of these tips.
Now, I'm going to apply
these tips one at a time,
and we'll see how
fast we can get the
build to become at the end, OK?
Before we start though,
I need to talk to you
a little bit about the
Santa Tracker project.
Because build
performance is really
dependent on the
project's characteristics.
So the Santa
Tracker is organized
into nine different modules,
including a wear module.
It has about 500 Java files.
It's pretty resource-heavy,
with thousands
of XML files and 3,500 pngs.
It uses multidex, no annotation
processors, and the final debug
APK is about 60 megabytes,
so it's fairly large.
If you would like to explore
more about this project,
you can find it on Google's
and GitHub account.
Now, for benchmarking
of this project,
I'm going to show you three
sets of numbers focused
on three build scenarios.
The first one is
simply a full build.
It's just a clean,
assemble debug.
The second one is a incremental
build with a Java change.
It's a one line Java change
in a method implementation.
And the third one
is an incremental
build with a resource change.
And it's a simple add or
remove string resource.
And we can measure the build
times for each of these.
Now just remember,
build times are
highly dependent on your
project's characteristics
and your build environment.
So you may get more or you may
get less out of these tips.
That is to say, actual
results may vary.
OK, so the first tip is to make
sure you use the latest Android
Gradle plugin.
With each release, we
make a lot of bug fixes,
and fix performance issues,
as well as introduce
new performance features.
So you want to make sure you
are able to leverage those.
Now, there are a couple
of things to note here.
First one is that starting
with the plugin 3.0,
we are going to distribute the
plugin through the new Google's
Maven repository that
we announced yesterday.
So you need to add that
Maven line at the top
to get the new plugin.
Second is that the plugin
often requires specific version
of build tools, as well as
specific versions of Gradle
itself.
So the easiest way
for you to do this
is, do the update
in Android Studio
because it will figure
out what it needs,
and make sure it's
the right combination.
And third, the 3.0 plugin
is a bit of an exception
because we introduced
some breaking changes,
so it might require a
little bit more work
on your part to update.
We have published
a migration guide,
and you'll see the link at
the end of the presentation.
And this was the
result that I got
after switching
the Santa Tracker
project from the old 2.2
plugin to 3.0 alpha 1.
Now, you can see that
immediately we shaved off
25% from the full build, 40%
from the incremental Java
change, and about 16%
for resource change.
Not bad for updating
to the latest plugin.
Now, second tip is to
avoid Legacy multidex.
Now, I think most of you
know that if your app exceeds
the 64k method reference limit,
you will need to use multidex.
But what you may not know is
that if your minSdkVersion is
lower than 21 and
you use multidex,
you will be using what's
called Legacy multidex, which
is a lot slower to build.
So you want to avoid that.
Now, if you usually start
your build in Android Studio
by hitting the Run button,
this doesn't really
apply to you because newer
versions of Android Studio
will automatically
detect the API
level of your connected
device or emulator image,
and switch to native
multidex if applicable.
But I also know a lot
of you are in the habit
of doing your builds
from the command line.
So if you want to
continue to do that,
you should define a
new product flavor.
Here, for example, I
call it development.
And simply set your
minSdkVersion to something
that 21 or above.
And on the command line, now you
can call assemble development
debug, and you will
avoid Legacy multidex.
And then these are the
results that I got.
We shaved another five
seconds off the full build,
a whopping eight seconds--
that's more than 50%
of what we had before.
And then incremental
build for resource change
is about the same
as you would expect.
Now, the third tip
here is that you
should disable multi-APK
generation for your development
build.
Now, you do this typically
by using the splits block
in a DSL.
Multi-APK allows you
to define dimensions
that you want to generate
multiple SDKs upon.
The idea here is that you
can tell it to generate along
dimensions like
ABI or density so
that it generates these multiple
APKs that are smaller in size.
Now, small APKs are great
for your release builds,
but they aren't that important
for your development builds.
So if you turn it on for
your development builds,
you'll be wasting time packaging
and creating these APKs
that you're not using.
Now, to disable multi-APK
generation properly,
you can't just disable
it in the splits block
because that block is global
to all your build variants.
So one way you
can do it properly
is to define a
property like here.
Here I've defined a
property called devBuild.
And I'm just going
to pass that property
to Gradle every time I
do a development build.
And if Gradle sees
that property,
it will set the splits.abi
and .density.enable to false,
and the multi-APK
generation will not happen.
Now, if you're using Studio,
you can also pass this flag
through the compiler
options under preferences
by adding -PdevBuild,
in this case.
With this flag,
every time Studio
does a build, it will also
pass the same flag to Gradle
so multi-APK generation
will not occur.
And these are the numbers I
got after disabling multi-APK.
Again, some more improvements
across the board.
Now, Tip 4 is to minimize
the set of resources
that you package in
your development build.
Now, by default,
the build system
will include the resources for
all the languages and screen
densities that your app and the
libraries that your app uses
define.
So if your app supports
many different languages,
or many different
screen densities,
then you're actually
wasting a lot
of time doing work for no reason
because during development
you're only ever,
probably, going to be using
one set of those resources.
Now to do this, you should
use the resConfigs keyword
and specify the language
and the screen density
that you need for your
development builds.
And then you can
see here on the full
build, we shaved off
in another 6 seconds,
24% off the incremental
build in Java change,
and 21% for the incremental
resource change case.
Continuing to make gains.
Next up is disabling
png crunching.
Now by default, AAPT will crunch
your pngs to reduce their size,
yielding you a smaller APK.
Again, that's a great thing
for your release APKs,
but not that important for
your development builds.
So to avoid png crunching,
you can use the same property
that we define, and have, at the
aaptOptions and cruncherEnabled
flag, to disable it if Gradle
sees that properly defined.
And again, on Gradle, whenever
you do a development build,
you can pass that property into
Gradle to avoid png crunching.
The other option to
avoid png crunching
is to convert all
your pngs into webp.
Now, webp is up to 25% smaller,
so you get a smaller APK
to boot.
Newer versions of Android
Studio also supports conversion
within the IDE, so you can
easily convert your pngs
into webp format.
Now, the only thing that
you need to be careful about
is the OS requirements.
If you're using Opaque
webps, API level 15 and above
will support them.
But if you have alpha channels
and support transparencies
in your webp, then you
need API level 18 or above.
So that is something
to be mindful of.
So these are the numbers that
I got after disabling png
crunching.
So you can see, we shaved
off 9 seconds off the full
build here, which is pretty.
Substantial but that's also
because the Santa Tracker
has a ton of pngs in them.
So previously, we were spending
a lot of time doing that.
And for the other ones, they
didn't really change that much.
Now here's the kicker--
when I looked at the
APK size with crunching
and without crunching, turns
out there was no difference.
Turns out Santa
Tracker was already
using pretty optimal
pngs to begin with,
and it was just doing png
crunching for no reason.
OK, Tip 6 is to use Instant Run.
So Instant Run was launched
in Android Studio 2.0.
Since then, we have
spent a lot of time
improving its reliability.
The version of Instant Run
that we are launching with 3.0
is massively different than 2.0.
We have removed a
lot of hacks that we
made to work around
platform limitations
to make things more reliable.
The trade off is,
Instant Run will now only
work on API level 21 or above.
Now, that does not mean you
can't have your app's min SDK
version set to lower.
It just means the
device that you're
running Instant App on
need to be 21 or above.
We've also tweaked that UI.
So instead of having a
single Instant Run button,
the button is now separated
into a run and an apply changes
button.
When you hit the
Run button, we will
try to do a cold
swap, and the acti--
the app, excuse me,
will always restart.
When you click
the Apply Changes,
we will try to do a
hot or warm swap first.
And that would push changes
directly into the live process.
Now, one thing to
note, though, is
that when you use
Instant Run, it
makes your lives a little
bit easier because we, again,
automatically look at the target
device, look at its API level,
and look at the set of resources
it needs, and automatically
built the minimal thing that
the target device requires.
So even if you didn't define
a separate product flavor,
you would automatically get
some of the optimizations.
And these are the
numbers that I got after.
Notice, there is--
we actually regressed
by seven seconds
for the full build.
The reason for that is that, in
order for Instant Run to work,
we have to do extra
work to shard the APKs,
and to do bytecode
manipulation to prepare
your app for future hot,
warm, and cold swaps.
So that's where the
seven seconds came from.
We're working to drive
that number down.
Now, hopefully you'll see that
for the incremental changes,
we shaved off three seconds
for each of those cases.
Hopefully after you do a few
of the incremental changes,
you would recoup the
initial build slow down.
Now, Tip 7 is a fun one.
It's that you should
avoid inadvertent changes
to your project.
And the code shown here
is an example of such.
At first glance, it
seems pretty reasonable.
The code here is basically
just using the current DateTime
as the version
code for your app.
Which is a reasonable
thing to do,
because every time
you build, you
want to have a unique ID so that
when your QA team logs a bug,
they can tell you
which build it was.
Now the reason
why this is bad is
because this would force your
Android manifest to change
at every build, even the
ones that you you are not
distributing to anybody.
Now, Santa Tracker
didn't have this problem,
but I simulated this by forcing
a manifest change every time.
And this was the result.
So as you can see,
if I had that code
in my project,
I would have added 3 seconds
to my incremental Java
build every time,
and 3.6 seconds
to my incremental resource
change every time.
That's huge.
And that's time spent
for no good reason.
Now, in the previous
example, you
can easily fix this by, again,
conditioning the setting
of the unique version code
based on the devBuild property
that we were using earlier.
So in this case, if that
property is defined,
then we set it to
a static value.
If not, we will
generate a unique value.
Now, having bad code
in your build script
is not the only way
to get into trouble.
I know a lot of you
use Crashlytics.
And it's a great product,
so it must be safe, right?
Well, that depends.
Turns out Crashlytics
by default will always
generate a unique build
ID on every build.
But they provide a flag
for you to turn this off.
So you need to be careful
about setting this flag.
You should set this
flag in your debug
build's or development build's
alwaysUpdateBuildID to false.
They also supply
a different flag
to disable Crashlytics
altogether,
and you can consider
using that as well.
Now, Tip 8 is that you should
not use dynamic versions.
Gradle provides a very
convenient way for you
to tell Gradle that, hey,
I want to use the latest
version of this library,
through this plus symbol here.
Now, it's bad for a
couple of reasons.
From a performance
perspective, that
will make Gradle check for
new versions of that library
every 24 hours, causing
your dependency resolution
time to increase.
Now, even if you are
OK with that hit,
it's still bad because it makes
your build nondeterministic.
You do a build today compared
to a build two weeks from now,
you might be building
completely different things
because the libraries have
changed underneath of you.
So please avoid doing this.
Tip 9 is that you should
be careful about the amount
of memory you're
giving to Gradle.
In Android Studio, when you
create a brand new project,
by default we will give Gradle
1.5 gigabytes of memory.
That might be a good
setting for your project,
or it might be a bad
we don't really know.
Because it really depends
on the characteristics
of your project.
So you should tweak this
setting to see what's optimal.
Now, another thing I want to
call out is that in our DSL,
we have this dexOptions
where we allow
you to set the javaMaxHeapSize
for the dex process.
This made a lot of sense
when dex was out of process.
But since the plugin 2.1, dex
is now in-process by default.
So you should not really
set this flag anymore.
So if you have it, you
can just delete it.
Now, the last tip here
is that you should
enable the new Gradle cache.
Now, if you were at the
What's New for Dev Tools talk
this morning, you might have
heard Xavier talk about this.
This is a new caching
mechanism from Gradle
where you can cache all the
task outputs from every task.
Now, this is different
from the build cache
that we introduced in Android
Studio 2.3, which only cached
pre-dexed external libraries.
Now, this cache uses the
same up to date mechanism,
but it doesn't only
work for the last build,
but it works for any previous
build from any location.
Which means it would
really speed up your
build when you switch
branches, and it will
enable distributed caching.
Because this is so
new, we haven't fully
taken advantage of
it yet in Canary 1,
but we are actively
working on this in 3.0.
So our advice to you is that
you should set this to true now,
turn it on.
And through the next
several Canarys previews
and eventually
stable, you should
see progressively
improved performance.
And these are the
numbers that I got
after turning on
the build cache,
even though we haven't fully
take taken advantage of it yet.
So you can see the full
build actually dropped down
by seven seconds, and it
negated the regression that
was introduced by Instant Run.
And the incremental build
actually got slightly slower.
That's something that
we're looking into.
So here are the
cumulative improvements
after applying all these tips.
The full build is now
three times faster.
The incremental Java
build is 12 times faster.
And the resource change is
also three times faster.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Now, here is a summary
of all the tips.
I have also created
a GitHub repo
if you want to be able to
reproduce some of these results
and experiment with some
of these tips yourselves.
And that's it for me.
Thank you, James.
[APPLAUSE]
JEROME DOCHEZ: All
right, so up to now,
you've seen a number
of tricks and tips
to help with the performance.
Now I would like to
talk a little bit more
about some more radical changes
you can do with your build
to leverage some of
the new feature that
comes with Gradle plugin 3.0.
And in particular,
I'd like to talk
about the multi-module projects.
So we've had multi-module
projects for a long time,
but we used to discourage it
because we had, quite honestly,
a lot of issues both in
Gradle and in Android
plugin around scalability.
As you had more
and more modules,
the thing was getting
slower and slower.
So we worked really hard
with Gradle to fix this.
And now we totally
recommend you to go
to the multi-module project
if that makes sense for you.
But what do you have to do?
So if you remember, or if
you have created projects
with Android Studio
from scratch,
any project Studio
created from templates
is a multi-module
project to start with.
It just has one,
but you can add it.
It's ready to be multi-module.
To do that, you just need to
include a few more subfolders
in your main settings.Gradle.
And then you can start moving
code from, say, the app
into the lib1 or the lib2.
Obviously this sounds very easy.
Modularity is not
easy, I can guarantee.
It's going to be painful
if you want to do this.
Not painful, but it's
going to be hard.
And it's not something you
should do over the weekend.
It's going to take some time.
However, we're going
to see that it has
a lot of improvements with it.
So here we have an
example of three modules--
the app, which is
importing the lib, which
itself is importing the lib 2.
As you can see, it is
a straight dependency.
We are using the compile
configuration to define this.
And as you do a code
change, before in 3.0,
say you're doing some
code change in lib 2,
you would start recompiling
lib1 because, say,
your code change may be
removing a public method.
So of course you
need to recompile,
whoever is using that
particular lib tool to make sure
that you not using that method.
But it will also retrigger
completion of app,
and that's because the compile
dependency is transitive.
That means that app,
which depends lib1,
kind of transitively
also depends on lib2 just
because lib1 itself
was importing lib2.
And that's some of the thing
that is going to change in 3.0.
Now, the first thing that
Gradle is giving us for free
is compilation avoidance.
So you don't have
to do anything.
You're going to reap some of the
benefits from it immediately.
And what they do is
that they came up
with the notion of an ABI.
An ABI is the Application
Binary Interface.
In simple terms,
it means basically
your public methods
and fields, anything
that can be invoked
outside of the module.
So you can have an ABI change,
or you can have a non-ABI
change, depending on whether
or not you are using a public--
you're changing a public API.
Now, a non-ABI change has
no impact on consumers.
If you're changing
the implementation
of a method which is
private, why should the--
or even if it's
public, actually,
if it's just implementation of
a method, none of the consumers
are going to be impacted by
this change of implementation.
So you don't have
to recompile them.
However, obviously, if you're
removing a public method
or changing a public
method signature,
this is an ABI change.
This will trigger consumer
modules to be recompiled.
So far it's pretty simple.
So let's look how it looks.
I have non-ABI change.
So something which is private
to lib2 is being changed.
Nothing is recompiled.
Now, I have an ABI change,
and we are going back
to the original case of
pre-3.0 recompilation.
I'm changing something
which is visibly lib2.
lib1, which is importing it
directly, has to be recompiled.
And app, which is
importing it transitively,
also has to be recompiled.
That's really very annoying
because why would you
want to recompile app?
From this diagram, it
seems pretty obvious
that app is not using lib2.
But the fact is
that, because it's
declared through this
compiled configuration,
Gradle does not know if
app is using the ability
to use the lib2 interface.
Basically, the compile leak,
the implementation detail
of lib1, which is the lib2,
to the consumers of itself.
That means that now app
can see lib1 and lib2,
and that's really,
really something
that needed to be changed.
Now, let's have a look
on how that really
ripples into when you have a
really big [INAUDIBLE] board
of modules.
Here we've got only
nine modules, that--
eight modules,
that's pretty simple.
But say you have 50 modules,
and you have one leaf module
at the very bottom, and you're
making a non-ABI code change.
So that has to be recompiled,
that's pretty obvious right?
Now, let's switch to
the ABI code change.
Let's say that now we
are changing a public API
of that really leaf module.
Of course we're going
to recompile it.
And then we're
going to recompile
all the immediate users.
But because they
are transitively
dependent on each
other, why, you're going
to compile the other ones, too.
And then eventually, you're
going to recompile the app.
Now, if you've had
250 modules, you're
going to recompile 250 modules.
And app-- when you've got an
SDK, common type of library,
this will happen quite a bit.
So basically what
Gradle realized
is that compile is all wrong.
And there was no
distinction between,
oh, I want to use this
library as an implementation
detail of my library,
but by no mean should you
be using the API
of this library,
because you should only be
using the API of my library.
Versus, oh yeah, not
only am I using this API,
but I'm offering each
API as part of mine.
As a composition, if you want.
So say, for instance, you are a
library and you're using Guava,
you want to provide your API.
It doesn't really
mean that you want
your users to use the
Guava API through you,
because that's really nasty
when you think of a time, right?
What about if you want to remove
Guava from your implementation
detail because now you're
using the new JDK collection
clusters, and Guava
is not useful anymore?
Why, you can't, because
you used in the past
to provide Guava as a transitive
dependency of your module.
So therefore you can
break your clients.
People can start using Guava
API through your module,
and that's it.
So really, this compiled
dependency was all wrong.
And all consumers
of a module consumes
all of their transitive
dependencies, which basically
was yielding way too
many details about how
you implement it.
So they came up--
Gradle came up with a new way
of declaring your dependencies.
Compile is not
deprecated, and it's
replaced by two new
configurations, either API
or implementation.
So you can see
here, I'm replacing
what I used to declare
X and Y with one
declares as an
implementation detail--
that's implementation.
So that means that I'm consuming
libx as an implementation
detail, but none of my
users will have access
to its implementation,
to its API.
However, I'm also using liby,
and I'm also offering its API
as part of my API.
I'm composing over
that particular module.
So this is strict
distinction between the two.
Now, API is basically the
equivalent of the old compile.
It's the easy way to go.
If you were to do a search and
replace by compile with API,
it would just work.
But we totally not
recommend doing this
because, again, you're going
to leak all your dependencies,
and that's a bad idea.
Better would be to
use implementation.
Then you clearly say, I'm using
an implementation details.
As an implementation
detail of my library,
I'm using this
module, and I am not
going to leak it to my users.
Seems pretty easy.
So in fact, you should
probably just do a search
and replace of all your compile,
replace it with implementation.
Your build might break because
some users of your library
somewhere was using actually
a dependency you were leaking.
The only thing that
you would have to do
is that it would have
to directly also declare
their dependency on whichever
module they were actually
using.
So it's a little bit more work,
but it shouldn't be too bad.
Now, let's look
how it looks like.
Again, if you do a non-ABI
change, nothing happens.
You're changing lib2.
lib1 and app are
not to be compiled.
No change here.
But if you switch
to the ABI change,
this was what we used to have.
Now with an ABI change, app
is not recompiled any longer.
Only lib1 would be recompiled
because lib2 2 is not
visible to app.
This may seem to be a
very little small detail.
But when you come back to
the example I gave earlier
where you had this ABI code
change at the leaf module,
you remember?
I was compiling, obviously,
the module that changes.
You're still going to
recompile all the modules that
imported directly, but it's
going to stop right there.
It's not going to
recompile anything else.
Now, here you can see,
I'm saving about 50%
of recompilation.
Not too bad.
But if you have an
application with 5,200
or whatever number
of modules, this
can be substantial saving, OK?
So it adds up.
You have compilation avoidance,
plus this API implementation
configurations.
You're going to get
much faster builds.
I want to talk about one last
final note on modularity.
When you have multiple
modules, Gradle
can build them in parallel.
We've had issues where
sometimes one task has
to run before a number of other
tasks waiting for it to finish
can be running.
When you do things
in parallel, you
don't have such issues anymore.
So this is really
a great advantage,
to use multi-core machines
when you have multiple modules.
Having multiple modules
is a great workaround
for the lack of some of
the incremental tasks.
As you may have heard by
now, and something which
is very important, javac task--
the task that compile your
Java code into class files,
is, in theory, incremental.
However, as soon as you start
using annotation processes,
we have to turn out
the incrementality
because some
annotation processes,
they want to see the world.
You know, they
want to see Dagger,
they want to see all
the injection points.
Are they all satisfied?
So even if you change
only one class,
you have to recompile everything
so that the annotation
processes can be fed,
and react appropriately.
Now, if you split this javac
task into multiple modules,
none of them will
be incremental.
But because they will be
much smaller, each of them,
they going to be much faster.
We try in the Gradle plugin
to provide some parallelism
within a task.
But it's difficult,
and it's limited.
And you will never get
as much parallelism
as if you are using
multi-module projects.
Now, let's say you've
been very good,
you've followed all
of James' steps,
you've tried to
understand what is wrong,
it's still slow, right?
So what is the next step
for you to understand?
What can you do to figure
out, why is my build slow?
Now, one thing to realize
is that slow builds are not
normal.
This is not a reality in
which you should be living.
Let me be very clear--
a full build that takes
10 minutes is not normal.
An incremental build that takes
almost the same amount of time
as a full build is
even less normal.
And finally, when you
change nothing and you run
the build again, and it seems
to rerun a number of tasks
but you don't know why
because you changed nothing,
this is clearly not normal.
So there are
scenarios like these
that you should be looking
into, and figuring out,
do I really have
to go through this?
Maybe there are
some stuff I can do
to make things better for me.
And we all know that
the build is a tax.
Nobody likes to pay taxes.
So understanding the build is
like paying taxes on taxes,
I understand that.
But you must understand
at some level
that you need to spend
some time into it,
to invest into understanding,
where is my build being spent?
Which task is taking time?
So that you can eventually
have a chance to improve it.
But what can go wrong?
Like we talked earlier,
third party plugins,
you have to be very careful
about the third party
plugins you're using.
Some of them are very
well-written, some of them
not so well.
Incorrect code organization.
That's particularly
true, for instance,
when you were coming from the
Eclipse side of things a few
years back where all the
source files were in the source
directory, like
AIDL, C++, and Java.
They were all in
the same folder.
So if you change one, it would
trigger all the tasks to rerun.
Some people like to build,
to customize all of their
build system.
And sometimes it goes
really, really wild.
And finally, some
incorrect settings.
But you need to
understand and spend
some time in the build system.
And I know this is not
something that you like to do.
You're app developers.
But as your project is growing,
you must spend some time.
Now, there are tools
to help you so that you
spend a minimum amount of time.
But before we get into
this, I forgot that slide.
One of the thing we repeatedly
see over and over again
with people who complain about
their slow build is the doLast.
doLast is bad.
Gradle cannot understand if your
task is now incremental or not,
because it doesn't know
what you're doing in there.
doLast is bad because most of
the time, up to date checks
will also fail because you're
probably writing something
somewhere, and it's in
the output directory
of the particular task, or
you're changing something
after the task run.
And so basically,
again, Gradle is lost.
So it will rerun
your task every time.
Avoid this type of things.
And one way that you can do that
is by writing your own plugin.
I know it sounds scary, but
believe me, it's not that bad.
You can write your own plugin.
You can put it in the
buildSrc directory, which
mean that it will be available
to all of your module
automatically.
Remember to profile it.
I profile my code everyday,
and I'm always surprised.
And instead of using doLast,
try to write a custom task
with proper inputs and outputs
so that Gradle can cache it,
Gradle can understand what
would make that task up to date
or not.
Now, you still don't get it.
I mean, it's still slow, and
you've been spending time
on this, and it's still slow.
So what can you do?
Next thing to do,
run with a dry-run.
This will tell you
how much time you're
spending in the configuration.
This should be a couple of
seconds, 10 seconds at best,
at maximum if you really
have a huge project.
If you start spending
way too much time there,
there's something wrong.
Some plugin somewhere is
doing something wrong,
and we need to
understand what it is.
[INAUDIBLE] that ways.
Then you should do a --info.
--info and is very useful.
It will tell you what
tasks are running, and why.
Again, you change none of your
source code, you rerun a build,
some tasks are
running and you know
why, the --info will tell
you exactly why this process
manifest task is running.
That's because the main
manifestation has changed.
Then you have to do some
detective work to figure out
who changed it-- because
obviously you didn't change it
yourself, but at least
it gives you a hint.
Next one is the profile, a
slightly more complicated tool
that will give you the ability
to look at all your tasks
and see how much time you
spent in each of them.
This is very high level.
This is very useful to
figure out that maybe one
task is dominating.
Most of the time
we've seen this,
one task takes 90% of
the time of your build.
Find out what it is, what is
it doing before you report.
And then, for the hardcore,
there is another profiler.
It's a tool which is provided
by Gradle, and it's great.
It gives you the ability to
profile and to benchmark.
The profile is the
most interesting one.
You can actually generate a
profiler information right
from there, which you can
use to file bug against us.
So if you think that you've
done all your homework,
your build is still slow, you
don't get it, run the profiler.
Give us your yourkit
profile information,
file a bug against
us, and then we'll
start looking into why
is your build slow?
Much better than just filing a
bug saying, my build is slow,
I don't know why--
not giving a build.Gradle,
not giving us any information.
This is not stuff
we can act upon.
With this, we can look into
why your build is slow.
Some resources.
This is what we've seen today,
Santa Tracker Project Fork.
Look at the Migration
Guide to Android Studio,
optimize your build speed,
look into the Gradle.
It's always like when
you receive a new JDK,
you look at the newest
things in the JDK,
when there is a new
Gradle, you should
look into what is the
new things in there.
There's always a bunch of useful
utilities that you can use.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]